for engineering
so paulo what has contributions to
controlling cyber
systems have been recognized in multiple
awards including the career award in
2005
the donald t ekman award in 2009 the
george xlb award in 2011 antonio roberti
price in 2015.
sorry colin you are still sharing
you are still sharing checking out the
audience
so paulo has been the chair and general
chair for several conferences
he is also uh hscc steering committee
chair and servant as editorial board in
ieee embedded systems letters
in the ieee transaction so for automatic
control
so paulo uh you are now uh it's your
your floor kalin
i finally managed to stop sharing thanks
me
let's see if this thing works
yeah we can see your your screen can you
see it now in full screen yes
yes yes okay all right so
what i'm going to do with this talk is
to just give you a few highlights of
something we've been working for the
past
i don't know seven or eight years on
trying to
reason about robustness in cyber
physical systems but
the most challenging part is really
thinking of robustness in discrete
systems if you wanna
and if you want think of these
criticisms of software systems
and um so if i want to convince you that
robustness is important
you know i have to give you some way of
defining what robustness is and
here's one definition coming from the
ieee glossary of software engineering
it says that it's the degree to which a
system or component
can function correctly in the presence
of invalid inputs
or stressful environmental conditions
depending on your background if you're
coming from control
you think of these invalid inputs as
disturbances
if you're coming from a computer science
background you may want to think these
are
violations of environment assumptions
the system you design has to work in a
certain environment
you make certain assumptions about the
environment when you design it
well but when you deploy it those
assumptions are going to be violated
and you still want your system to
descend to do something
reasonable ideally something good
so the idea of robustness and
ways of reasoning and formalizing it has
been around for quite some time
so let me tell you how people think
about robustness in control theory
and the modern way of looking at
robustness
was introduced in 1989 by eduardo sontag
and in particular introduced this notion
of input to state stability
and so what is the desired behavior in
this case that the solution of the
differential equation
stays at zero starts in says zero for
all time
and what's the environment assumption
there are no disturbances
here the disturbances are represented by
the d letter on the differential
equation
so if we start at the origin and d is
equal to zero we stay at the origin
forever
that's the objective now he came up with
this way of defining iss
given by that inequality that you see up
there i'm not going to describe it
i'm just going to measure that it
captures two properties
described at the bottom of the slide
first
that small changes in the assumption
that is if the disturbance instead of
being zero
it becomes non-zero but small will force
the state
not to be at the origin but close to the
origin
in other words the bounded disturbance
leads to a bounded consequence that is
it's not the case that the small
disturbance will lead to a catastrophic
uh consequence and the second
is that even if there are disturbances
as soon as they disappear
the system recovers and therefore comes
back to the origin
original operating point
now if i want to explain this with the
picture
in red we see the solution of the
differential equation that it's supposed
to converge to the blue point which is
the origin
and it's not converging because there is
a disturbance but because the
disturbance is small
it doesn't deviate too much from the
blue dot
so small disturbances small consequences
of course if at some point the
disturbances disappear
the system is supposed to recover
and that's what happens disturbance
disappear the system returns back to its
operating point
now the very same notion had been
introduced in computer science
20 or 30 years before in a very nice
paper by dystra like a two or three page
paper where it talks about the notion of
self-stabilization
it also has a formal definition and i'm
not going to go through the formal
definition again i'm going to give you a
picture
and show that it captures exactly the
same that had been discovered in control
theory
20 or 30 years later so here in blue
what i'm showing is the desired behavior
and
this is what the system should be doing
staying in that
blue region of states now if a
disturbance occurs
here denoted by the red transition the
system will move away from the blue
region
but will always be captured in the gray
region
again this notion that small
disturbances
should have small consequences here
bounded disturbance will have bounded
consequences
as long as there are disturbances there
is other red transitions the system
stays
in the grey region but if the
disturbances disappear
then the system recovers and goes back
to the blue region
exactly like the definition in control
so
independently this idea that
small disturbances should have small
consequences
and absence of disturbances should let
the system recover
is what people intuitively think of
robustness
now depending on the framework depending
on the setting the framework may be
different the formalization may be
different
but you know completely different
communities thought about the same
concept
so we took this as our starting point
and we wanted to then
take this notion as a notion of
robustness and see how we could use it
for cyberphysical systems
now there's one important difficulty
here is that in both of these notions
the desired behavior the nominal
behavior
corresponds to a safety property staying
a given set of states
or staying at the urgent safety property
things become much more challenging when
you want to define robustness
for aliveness property because this
notion of recovering is no longer
trivial there's no set of states you're
supposed to
return to if you think in term in
topological terms
now safety properties correspond to
closed sets
but liveness properties can respond to
dense sets there's no
no notion of distance to a then set
there's no notion of convergence
things become much more challenging so
what we
what we did instead was well
let's use temporal logic as a way of
trying to extend these notions of
robustness to get something a little bit
more interesting it would also capture
likeness properties now today i'm only
going to
talk about the fragment of ltl that only
has
always in eventual operators blocks and
diamond but
we did the work for a full ltl but here
i'm just going to focus on this case
because it's easier to describe
and let me try to capture the notion of
robustness we had before
so because we were dealing with the
nominal behavior were safety properties
let's say that the assumption is always
p p is an atomic proposition so that's a
safety property
under that assumption we should have
always q
now how do i capture the fact that once
these third must disappear
once the assumptions that were violated
now start being forced the system
recovers
well i simply weaken
the assumption from always p to
eventually always be
and then rather than not being able to
claim
anything about the consequence as it
would be the case in classical logic
i'm going to say that because i weakened
the assumption
i still want the weakened version of the
guarantee to hold true
and the weakened version of the
guarantee will be eventually always q
so you can think that eventually always
p is the assumption at some point become
satisfied
and therefore at some point the
guarantee will become satisfied
now this captures what we saw before but
how do we go beyond that
can we keep on weakening the assumptions
and weakening guarantees
to get you know handle robustness for a
larger class of properties
and in logical terms this has to do
with which truth value would i give to
always p
so always p being satisfied means that p
has to be true
all the time that's the picture at the
top eventually always
i think of it as always p with the delay
provided that i discard
some initial prefix then i really have
always p
can i further weaken this and yes
i could say that instead of having p
satisfied with the delay
it will be intermittently satisfied so
it's still satisfied
infinitely many times but now violated
infinitely many times
even worse than that if it's satisfied
just finally many times
and even worse than that is that if it's
never satisfied
what does this mean in logical terms
that i really think of the top picture
as being true always piece through but
now
all these different ways in which always
p satisfy is violated
now they correspond to different shades
of false
and clearly i have a preference among
them i should not treat all of them as
being the same
as it's done in ltl in ltl all of these
simply mean false
now i want to assign different truth
values
and it will be convenient to think of
them as tuples of four bits
and i have a clear preference among them
0 1 1 is preferable over all the others
but if i don't have 0 1 1 1 then i
prefer that it's satisfied infinitely
many times
and if not then i get to 0 0 1 and so on
and so forth
so what it suggests is that i take this
set of truth values that is linearly
ordered according to my preferences
and then i want to build a logic that
uses these as my set of trust values
now this will be a many valid logic i
will have five different truth values
and when we give define the semantics of
a logic with many truth values the
algebraic structure you need to have
on your set of truth values is called
the residuated lattice
so it's a lattice so that you have
boolean operators
and it has this operation of residue
which lets us define implication
and so once we figure out that this is
what we wanted to do now we wanted to
find
a residuated lattice for these five
thrust values
that would have this specific negation
so what is this negation capturing
well if something is true 1 1 1 1
1 that's how we were interpreting the
top value in the lattice
negation should be false i should move
it to the bottom value
0 0 0 and then all the other shades of
false because they still correspond to
false when i negate them
they should become true which is the top
value of melodies
now if you look into the literature one
one speaks of
many valid logics the classical example
there are many reasons why the classical
example is always given by
intuitionistic logic and if you look at
the negation intuitionistic logic
it's not the negation we want it's the
dual
it's like flipping all the truth values
and we went through the literature for
quite some time
and all you know most work that people
have
done was based on intuitionistic
negation
so you know it took us quite some time
to figure out how to proceed
what was the right residual that lattice
to to
to use and eventually we found the paper
you know quite recent at the time at the
time this paper was like five years old
talking about dualizing intuitionistic
negation
and the motivation for that actually
came from
the work that the brazilian logician
had done in the 70s that you know 30 or
40 years later
they figure out how to do it better and
they had to dualize intuitionistic
communication
and they figure out what was the right
algebraic structure to do this
and this algebraic structure is called
the acosta algebra
in honor of that brazilian logician
okay so now with the cost algebra we can
define the semantics for this new logic
that we called
robustic robust linear temporal logic
so how do we define the semantics
through a valuation function
that's a function that takes a formula
an infinite string of sets of
values for the atomic propositions now
if my formula is just an atomic
proposition the
the semantics is classical i see if the
atomic proposition is satisfied
at the first entry of my string and
therefore as it's true otherwise it's
false
and here i want to contrast these with
many other approaches to define
robustness in temporal logic like in
stl where the robustness comes
from the way in which atomic
propositions are interpreted
here they're interpreted classically so
that's not what we were doing so
any approach that constructs robustness
by either interpreting atomic
proposition say on the real numbers or
on a lattice
is orthogonal to what we're doing and in
fact can we combine what we're doing
robustness in our case will actually
come from time and that's already
embedded in ltl
so for the boolean operations we just
directly transform them to the
operations
in the dacosta algebra that's why you
have to find the acosta alger
and now what we have to define is what's
the interpretation of
the temporal operators and if i look at
the box operator
that in robust ltl we put a little dot
just to distinguish it
the interpretation is very similar to
what i had before
well the top value corresponds to having
always five satisfied
the value below corresponds to have
eventually always satisfied and so on
and so forth
and for the eventually there are only
two things that can happen either
eventually satisfied
or it is not so that representation
corresponds to eventually phi
at all the bits on the truth values
so good we came up with some definition
for a new temporal logic now the
question is
did we get something that's right and
how do we know if you get it right well
we're going to measure this into
different ways expressiveness do we get
interesting examples and tractability
can we solve verification and synthesis
problems and how complex well is
decidable and how complex
are they so first the formula we started
to give
to motivate all of these was box dot
p implies box dot q and i talked about
weakening the assumption and weakening
the guarantee do we actually get that
and indeed we get that to get the top
value of in our logic for this formula
what needs to happen
is that if always p holds we need to
guarantee always q
but if we can always p to eventually
always p
we have to guarantee eventually obvious
q and if you further weaken it
we get the corresponding we can
guarantee and so on and so forth
so yes that that we use as motivation is
directly guaranteed by the semantics of
the logic
i just write box p implies box q
and i always have all these guarantees
that as you weaken the assumption
you guarantee that you weaken the
guarantee you don't just fail
catastrophically
let's look at this other formula is a
formula that appears in many papers
and that it says that every occurrence
of p that we seek as a request should
eventually be followed by an
occurrence of q which is a grant
let's see what's interpretation of this
in rltl
and this is what interpretation is and
what i would like to call your attention
to
is when we weaken when we look at the
truth values below the top what we
obtain
is something that had also appeared in
the literature in a
completely unrelated way and it appears
so many times that even as a name the
first one is called
strong fairness or compassion and the
second one
is called weak fairness or justice so
those
formulas that appeared in literature in
a completely different context
are now unified and now we have an
explanation as to why people thought
about this
they're just weakened versions of this
formula
asking that requests are full eventually
followed by occurrence of grants
so the fact that we captured these
formulas that appeared in a completely
unrelated
nature in the literature and now we give
an explanation as to why they're useful
suggests that somehow the the semantics
we define is
you know a reasonable one
how about um expressiveness well
every rltl formula when they define the
semantics we had this form
yes yes absolutely so uh so you only
have this
four valued semantics because you only
looked at
ltl would always and eventually ah
very good question did you have you said
you have a result for full ltl so if you
keep on adding
operators you're gonna you're you're
you're gonna have more more than four
right
so with full ltl i still have five truth
values
uh you know we write it like four but
you count the zeros and ones it just
ends up being five
and the reason is the following that we
wanted to reuse
every single algorithm that was
developed for ltl
and that will then mean that the logic
that we introduce has to be
as expressive as ltl and that's the
reason why we cannot go beyond these
five
i can also define a semantics that we
could have
uncountable or countably infinite
number of truth values but then it
becomes more expressive than
ltl and then the standard algorithms no
longer work and so on and so forth
so that was kind of by design nice okay
thanks
what about nesting if you would have
nesting you know would this increase
you know yeah no even if you have
nesting you remain with five through
failures so the semantics we define
uh for the general ltl yes allows for
the nesting alloys for everything
so in terms of expressiveness as i was
saying before
we have these four bits we can write an
ltl formula for each bit
and this this would then show that um
ltl and rltl are equally expressible
now this also shows that the
verification and synthesis problems are
decidable because i can convert
everything into ltl formulas
now the problem with this is that this
translation
incurs an exponential blow up so if we
follow this route we won't really know
know what's the complex or intrinsic
complexity
of both verification and synthesis in
rltl because of this exponential blow up
so what we did was to try to solve this
problem directly
and what we were able to show is that
yes
both verification and synthesis they are
decidable
but their time complexity is the same as
ltl
and so here's a little table where we're
comparing ltl with rltl
and the only difference you see is that
there's a 2 that gets replaced with the
5.
and the reason for that is ltl is bull
two valued
that's why i have a two and now we have
a logic that is five valued that two
becomes a five because we need to
account for those
five truth values and i say that the
complex is the same because i can always
convert these two into a five by putting
a constant multiplying the exponent so
these two become
this five becomes a two and then they're
both uh
the complexity class is essentially the
same
now interestingly we can do
even better if we focus on a smaller
fragment of rltl
we can bring the complexity of rltl even
closer to ltl
and we did this by understanding what
are the operators in ltl that really
give us trouble
and it turns out that it's the
implication operator that tends to give
a struggle
and so if we define a fragment of rltl
where all the formulas only have one
implication they're of the form
phi implies psi but neither phi or sign
has an implication
in reality we allow for certain kinds of
implications but to simplify
let's say there's only one implication
at the top level
then in this case what we can show is
that the complexity of verification
is given by this expression here where
you have if you want to think a
combination
between being exponential with base 2
and being exponential with base 3
and what that k that appears there it's
counting the number of sub formulas that
have a box dot operator
so if there are no block stock operators
k becomes zero and recover the
complexity of ltl
the more box dot operators we have the
more we're moving complexity from
a base of two to a base of three in
either case
now instead of the bound being having a
base of five now it has a base of three
so it becomes even closer to the
complexity of
ltl and
now the other question is okay so this
seems interesting but this fragment
does it really capture interesting
properties well there's something called
the beauty store
which has lots and lots of examples of
bq automating their corresponding
formulas
and so went to the store and we found
that about 95 percent of those formulas
can be written in this fragment so from
that perspective this fragment is indeed
interesting
and then we also looked at this
challenge called the rigorous
examination of reactive systems
where we're given systems and formulas
and we try to
write the corresponding formulas in our
ltl just by putting these dots
on the box and eventual operators and we
try to see that
if we solve those problems is it the
case that when we evaluate the problems
the foreigners would have the top value
in our logic and the bottom value
if that was the case there's no need for
our logic we should instead be
using ltl or do we have all the truth
values in between
and they do have the three values in
between for example in 164
formulas that we analyzed we saw that
for example 14
of them would be false according to ltl
but the truth value which is the second
highest meaning that
even though they don't satisfy the
specification they're
pretty close to satisfying the
specification so
instead of doing verification with ltl
if we do rltl
we actually give this information to the
designer that
specification is not satisfied but
you're very close to meeting the
specification
and this can then be very useful to
tweak the design and actually get it to
the level that you want
and even for the formulas that are
falsified if you
um check them using ltl uh we saw
similar phenomena that they are said
they are falsified but some of them
they're pretty close to being
true so uh again showing that
if you do verification with rltl you can
give very useful information
to the users now the last thing we did
was to do an empirical complexity
of the overhead we have to do rltl
verification
disfragment versus ltl here's how we did
that
so the theoretical bounds are three
raised to the length of the formula for
rltl
and two raised to the length of the
formula for ltl
as i mentioned before that 3 i can
convert it to a 2
by having a constant on the exponent and
this constant is 1.59
so what we said was well rather than
using these bounds let's actually
compute this constant
empirically by doing examples so i can
determine that concept empirically
by computing the running time that i
need to verify
formulas on a given system and then
computing that empirical value
and we did several examples in these
examples the constant actually range
from 1.016
to 1.058 so much smaller than
the bound that we had there and then if
you plot these on the logarithmic scale
that constant is just the slope of this
curve and you're basically seeing the
same thing that the slope of this curve
is very close to being one
meaning that the overhead in running
time compared with ltl for this fragment
is fairly small
so it's in summary
lots of formulas can be written in the
fragment if you use it for verification
the overhead in terms of running time is
low
and you give very useful information to
the designer because
you give it much more
detailed information about whether or
not properties are satisfied in a robust
manner
and even if they're not satisfied how
close they are
from being satisfied so i hope that i
convinced you that robustness
is essential property of every
well-designed system
rltl is a convenient way of
specifying and verifying and even
synthesizing
robust systems if you want why
convenient
the the syntax is so close to ltl
that you can reuse every ltl formula and
you saw us doing that we just went to
repositories and we just reused those
formulas
and because in the back engine of rltl
is based on algorithms that were
developed for ltl
every time there's an improvement in ltl
we can reuse those algorithms
to make the verification for rltl even
faster
now the synthesis problem here is
relatively unexplored
we show that it's decidable you know we
have this complexity by using standard
algorithms
but still we haven't spent enough time
to see
if we can develop customized algorithms
or finding fragments for which
the complexity of synthesis could be
further reduced
as we did for ldl and with this
i would like to thank rado for inviting
me
my students and post docs that worked
together with me
you have here some references in case
you're interested in looking at some
more details
and i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you very much paulo here is your
applause so i i would
like to mention that it was not only me
that invited you it was also
uh
so we all absolutely and i like to think
about all of them thank you all
and so now i think that that is
the chair for this uh for this session
to ask the following question so colleen
had
rules uh you know he had an ordering
among the rules
you have also ordering so can you take
kalin rules and write them in rldl
uh so he was using
slt stl so stl
has an ltl you know chord built in there
so if we disregard how the inter
atomic propositions are being
interpreted yes we can write the rules
here
and i'm sure that what we did for from
going from ltl to rltl can be done from
stl to rstl
but he had what if he had a higher view
i mean he had this ordering you know and
it was like three levels but what if he
has like
six levels in in his ordering so there
are only four
uh yes so yes
so that's that's a different question um
because the ordering i have it's
intrinsic to the logic in the sense that
to give to define a semantics you need
an algebraic structure and the algebraic
structure
in in general well you also have logics
where the truth values are not linearly
ordered
but in our case they're linearly ordered
i think in kalin's example this
was not embedded in the semantics of the
logic
yeah of course no it came on top of this
right
paula really really quickly can you tell
us like in two sentences how do you
actually do verification
oh for for this fragment though so when
you do verification
first the question you pose is a bit
different it's not is it true or false
one way of posing it is is the truth
value at least
this it's like deciding between being
above this truth value or below this
you don't run you don't run like an ltl
model checker four times
we we do yes we do it we do and then
what we do in this fragment to make it
more efficient is that
we start with the lowest bit and then we
check the value of the lowest bit
if the value of the lowest bit is zero
there's no need to check all the other
values
we already know they're all zero if it's
one with insertion we move to the next
bit
and we keep on doing like that so in the
worst case we do
four ltl verifications or we invoke
an ltl verifier four times
so use it off the shelf you don't you
don't construct yourself the book
automatically
no i use off the shelf and what i do is
this interface where i
grab my formula decompose it figure out
which formula do i verify now
and what do i do next so this is this is
was also by design so that
every time there's a faster verifier i
can then latch onto that
and then make the verification of rltl
so faster
and for synthesis you said this
decidable you just showed that basically
you can reach some sets
so for synthesis we use the classical
algorithm which is
you go to the bukit automata
construction and then you do a
determinization
and all of that stuff however we don't
know how to
optimize this process the way we did for
this fragment for verification
there we don't know how to optimize it
some other guy you're going to have like
a different acceptance condition for
each of the
lto things uh so we have different types
of accepting states
yes exactly and for each so it's
actually not accepting states is
actually the initial states
we have five initial states or five
classes of initial states
and rents from a different class would
give us different truth values
okay all right so uh i see that uh
is getting a little bit nervous so i
would like now to
to give the opportunity to rujita to
introduce
are you there